무려 5년 만에 거의 100억이
올랐어요. 지금 안 팔았으면은 진짜
엄청난 시세 체액을 누렸을 텐데 너무
아쉽습니다. 그래서 이것도 중요한 거
같아. 그러니까 건물 이렇게 좋은데
투자하면 뭐 몇 천만 원 요구하는
업체도 있고 심지어는 막 몇억
요구하는 업체들도 굉장히 많습니다.
굳이 그렇게까지 줄 필요가 없어요.
차라리 공사비를 더 쓰세요.
네. 안녕하세요. 어, 이번 주도
제가 뉴스 기사를 좀 준비해
왔습니다. 우선 첫 번째 뉴스 기사
좀 보면은 꼬마 빌딩 투자 자동 증식
시대 끝났다라는 내용의 기사인데 딱
보시면 알겠지만 일단은 업체
광고입니다. 업체가 이제 쓴 것으로
좀 보여지는데 일단 여기 내용들을 좀
엮겨 보면은 시장에서는 시세 이하의
혁신적인 할인을 기대하기 어렵다.
그래서 반드시 경매 또는 MPL
시장을 결합해야지만 싸게 살 수
있다. 뭐 이런 내용들이 있는데 물론
이렇게 해서 말대로 되면은 좋은데
보통 좋은 건물들은 경매나 이런
MPL 시장 나오기 전에 매각이
됩니다. 여기 나온 매물들이 반드시
좀 좋은 거다. 단정 짓긴 좀
어려워요. 저는 고객들한테 항상
얘기하는게 물론 이제 싸게 사는게
되게 중요하긴 하지만 위치가 제일
중요하거든요. 위치 좋은 거를 뭐
싸게 사는게 아니라 그냥 적정가
아니면 시세 정도 아니면 비싸게라도
사라 그러거든요. 여기서는 경매나 막
다 넘어가는 매물을 싸게 사라 뭐
이런 내용이 있는데 그거를 일단
현실적으로 사기도 어렵고 제 생각에는
확률적으로 봤을 때는 그냥 시장에
있는 거 위치 좋은 거를 차라리
비싸게 사는게 맞습니다. 그게 이제
임대적인 측면으로도 그렇고 나중에
매각하기에도 그렇고 좋다라고 저는
생각을 합니다. 쭉 넘어가서 뭐 시공
공사를 어떻게 해야 되는지 뭐 이런
내용들이 있는데 일단은 업체 광고이고
수수료를 좀 요구할 수도 있어요.
물론 이제 처음에 막 이렇게 공사하고
이러는데 되게 좀 어려울 수 있다라고
생각은 하지만 뭐 몇 천만 원
요구하는 업체도 있고 심지어는 막
몇억 요구하는 업체들도 굉장히
많습니다. 굳이 그렇게까지 줄 필요가
없어요. 차라리 공사비를 더 쓰세요.
이렇게까지 줄 필요는 없는 거
같습니다. 그리고 다음 기사 볼게요.
그리고 로보이 바꿀 부동산 시장
변화에 따른 투자 전략을 세워라라는
기사인데 저는 어느 정도는 대체가 될
거 같아요. 그래서 뭐 쉽게
설명드리면 텔레 마케터분들 있잖아요.
그래서 예전에 테란로에 정말 테레
마케터들이 사용하는 오피스가 굉장히
많았거든요. 근데 요즘에는 이렇게
AI로 대체가 좀 되기 시작했어요.
그런 업체들이 그렇게 많은 오피스
면적을 좀 필요로 하진 않거든요.
이런 AI나 이런 로봇한테 대체가
되는 업종들이 좀 생겨날 거거든요.
그래서 그걸로 인해서 오피스 면적은
좀 많이 줄어들 거 같아요. 뭐
최근에 예를 들면 변호사님 같은
경우에도 AI 이렇게 학습시키면은
서면이나 이런 것도 써 주거든요.
AI가 부동산 중개업도 비슷할 거
같아요. 그래서 전체적으로 어찌 됐든
이런 뭐 전문적인 지식을 요구하거나
이런 업종 같은 경우에는 AI가
그래도 어느 정도 대체된다라고 생각이
되기 때문에 장기적으로는 오피스
사용하는 업체들 수요는 계속 좀
줄어들 가능성이 굉장히 좀 크지
않나? 네. 그렇게 생각을 합니다.
그리고 더 나아가서는 그니까 중국
쪽에 오피스를 많이 짓고 있어요.
그래서 2027년 2028년도 이제
중공 완료 예정인데 그때 아마 공급이
굉장히 좀 많이 늘어날 것 같아요.
2027년도나 28년도에 이제 그
건물들이 준공이 되다 보면은
전체적으로 좀 오피스 가격에 좀
영향이 있지 않을까 뭐 그렇게 좀
예상도 하고 있습니다. 그래서 좀
멀리 봤을 때는 오피스 수요는 좀
줄어드는데 반대로 주거 수는 좀 많이
늘어날 것 같아요. 아무래도 집에서
생활을 많이 하다 보니까 이런 주거
수요는 좀 더 늘어날 것 같다. 이런
예상도 좀 합니다. 그리고 더
나아가서는 미래일이 어떻게 될지
모르겠지만 진짜 뉴욕처럼 이런
오피스도 주거로 바꾸는 그런 시대에도
오지 않을까 싶습니다. 만약에 공실이
되게 심해질 경우에. 그래서 지금
뉴욕이나 막 이런데 보면은 오피스를
주거로 좀 많이 바꾸고 있거든요.
나중에 이렇게 좀 대체도 많이 되고
오피스 수요들이 줄고 근데 공급은
되게 많은 상태에서 계속 공실로
납드는게 아니라 주거로 바꾸는 그런
시장도 좀 오지 않을까? 네.
조심스럽게 이렇게 예상하고 있습니다.
그리고 또 다른 기사 볼게요. 그리고
이제 뭐 아파트 관련된 기사들이
굉장히 요즘 많은데 어 양극화가 다
심해진다라는 기사들이 좀 많아요.
앞으로 더 심해질 거 같고 빌딩도
똑같습니다. 앞으로 오르는데만 오르고
인대가 되는 곳만 될 거 같아요.
그래서 지금 요즘에 뭐 빌딩 산다라고
하면은 진짜 확실히 오를 만한데 진짜
비싸더라도 확실히 임대가 되고 매각이
될 만한데 그런 데를 좀 많이
추천하고 있습니다. 그리고 뭐 연예인
분들 기사도 좀 보면은 뭐 21억
건물주 엄지원 뭐 이렇게 최근에 이제
다시 나오나 봐요. 근데 저는 진짜
엄지 씨 너무 좀 안타까운게 막
오르기 전에 팔았어요. 너무 아깝게
팔았어요. 그러니까 지금 16년도에
15억에 매입한 다음에 20년도에
41억 정도에 팔았어요. 이게 돼지가
한 50평 정도 되거든요. 근데 여기
지금 건물 위치가 연무장길이에요.
그래서 연무장길 최근에 제가
말씀드렸지만 한 3억 이상에
팔렸거든요. 그래서 대입해 보면
150억이 넘는 건물이에요. 무려
5년 만에 거의 100억이 올랐어요.
지금 아직 안 팔았으면은 진짜 엄청난
시세 체액을 누렸을 텐데 너무
아쉽습니다. 그래서 이것도 중요한 거
같아. 그러니까 건물 이렇게 좋은데
투자하면 부동산에서 팔려고 연락 엄청
많이 오거든요. 근데 이제 그거에
현혹돼 가지고 파시는 분들이 굉장히
많습니다. 진짜 괜찮은 위치 같은
경우에는 진짜 안 파는게 돈 버는
거예요. 너무 안타깝네요. 아 물론
이제 싸게 사 가지고 차익을 많이
보긴 했지만 단순 차익만 뭐 약
26억이라고 하긴 하지만 지금
납뒀으면 100억 이상의 차익이 있지
않았을까? 뭐 임대료도 굉장히 높게
맞췄을 수 있을 것 같아요. 너무
안타깝습니다. 또 마지막 기사
볼게요. 성동구 24억 꼬마빌 건물주
거는비 뭐 이렇게 건음비 씨가 아마
송정동에 매입한 걸로 알고 있는데
저는 그때도 설명드렸지만 그니까 이제
성수동 상권이 확장해서 그게
북성수까지 이어지고 거기다 성정까지
갈 거다라고 하면은이 대로를
넘어간다라는 건 굉장한 일이고 저는
개인적으로 성정동을 그렇게 권하진
않거든요. 차라리 북성수까지 어떻게
모르겠는데 성정도까지는 올라가기가 좀
쉽지 않을까? 근데 권는음빛이
대단하네요. 네. 이제 그런 거
같습니다. 일단 보셔야 될게 제목
이런 거에 현혹돼서 많이 보긴 하지만
실질적으로 내용을 봤을 때 좀 팩트와
좀 다른 부분을 부풀려서 하는 경우도
꽤 있거든요. 요런 것들을 좀 자세히
보신 다음에 1등 투자하는데 있어서
좀 도움 되시면 좋을 거 같고 그리고
깨알 홍보를 좀 하자면 11월 초에
저희 스터디를 시작합니다. 그래서
저희가 36기까지 하면서 정말 많은
수정 보안을 했습니다. 빌딩
투자하시는 분들은이 강의 들으시면 꼭
좋을 것 같습니다. 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요. 다음 시간에
뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]